I think in this world of communication
there's a different way to fight and
deliver your message to yet stand your
ground but at the same time maintain a
relationship with the other individual
that is an art it's not easy to do it's
very hard and the way you do it is by I
think what is unattractive is the
following is when you're 100 I'm right
you're wrong you're an idiot you're a
and some people do it that way I
don't think you're opening up the door
to want to have that exchange I think if
there's an opportunity to say listen man
find some leaks of my argument what do
you think I love that you do that yeah
it's a cool thing maybe I'm off yeah I'm
okay with that